bonsoir messieurs et merci d'être en
direct ce soir avec nous sur rt france
sur le couvre feu donc avancer dès 18h
dans le nous dans deux nouveaux
départements quelle peut-être à le réel
impact sur la circulation du virus et
scott deux heures de plus ça change
quelque chose pour une eau mega man
alors bourreau essayer de vous répondre
et posé de l'argumentation
il faut bien comprendre quel est
l'objectif du couvre-feu
donc tout d'abord c'est un compromis
entre les nécessités sanitaires et bien
sûr le maintien d'une certaine vie
économique et sociale pour réduire la
pression sur l'hôpital et répondre quand
même la lassitude de la population
l'objectif en fait est de diminuer les
interactions or les circonstances
principale pendant lesquelles se font
les contaminations ce sont les réunions
intra familiales ou entre amis celles ci
se font essentiellement le soir il est
donc important de les réduire en
installant ce couvre-feu
alors on s'est rendu compte en fait que
la population est capable de s'adapter
lorsque le travail se termine à 18
heures eh bien on va essayer de faire
ces fameuses réunions avant 20 heures
puisque le couvre-feu est décidé à 20h
et donc le fait de le ramener à 18
heures pourrait bien sûr empêcher ces
sorties empêcher les personnes d'aller
notamment faire des queues pour
récupérer le repas du soir et peut-être
contribué à contenir la circulation du
virus
christophe prudhomme vous partager ce
point de vue c'est ça un bon compromis
un couvre feu dès 18h est ce que
finalement la meilleure solution ça ne
reste toutefois pas le confinement
écoutez rahan ces deux heures
le couvre feu je pense pas que c'est une
incidence majeure sur la circulation du
virus comme ça été dit par mon collègue
le problème c'est d'insister auprès de
la population sur le fait que la
transmission se fait lors des réunions
dans des lieux clos et donc il faut
diminuer le nombre de personnes que l'on
voit en particulier dans ces
départements
voilà donc je pense pas que le discours
soit adaptée c'est à dire que on passe
voyez de la discours sur l'efficacité du
confinement puis maintenant c'est le
vaccin il ya eu les tests ce qu'il faut
c'est avoir une cohérence dans la
stratégie sachant qu'on a maintenant
plusieurs armes à disposition
il faut les utiliser au mieux sachant
que on a vu que le le confinement
avaient des effets quand même négatif
sur la santé de l'ensemble de la
population
voilà il ya des conséquences aujourd'hui
de se confirme en particulier
moi je constate dans le samu dans lequel
je travaille un problème majeur au
niveau psychologique chez les jeunes
étudiants qui aujourd'hui sont en grande
difficulté pour pouvoir poursuivre leurs
études ils ont de grandes inquiétudes
sur l'avenir donc faut qu'il y ait un
équilibre et je pense pas que se
focaliser et mais qu'on passe notre
temps à discuter de l'avancement de deux
heures du confinement ça soit le plus
important je pense qu'il faut insister
sur le fait que quand on est dans un
département où le virus circule
activement et bien il faut réduire le
nombre de personnes que l'on rencontre
et ça il faut insister là dessus c'est à
dire que la responsabilité individuelle
de chacun sait ce que vous nous dites
pas responsabilité individuelle de
chaque cas vous savez que ce qui est
quand même assez étonnant dans notre
pays
c'est que voyez quand vous prenez le
fait que 60 % de la population soit
disons réticente à la vaccination mais
qu'elle se soit le même chiffre de
population qui n'est pas confiance dans
le gouvernement c'est qu'il ya un
problème par rapport à la communication
du gouvernement et à la manière dont il
transmet les informations
c'est à dire que je pense que on les
chèques en terme de 100
public c'est un échec de communication
le gouvernement n'a vu qu'un certain
nombre de pays ont fait beaucoup mieux
et ça c'est de la responsabilité du
gouvernement c'est à dire que il faut
arrêter de faire des allers-retours en
se focalisant pendant une semaine sur
une mesure l'autre semaine sur une autre
île sachant qu'aujourd'hui vous savez ce
qui est le plus important c'est pas
d'avancer de deux heures le confinement
c'est dans ces départements moi j'aurais
bien aimé qu'on mettre le paquet sur la
vaccination dans ces départements
justement la vaccination qui inquiète
beaucoup aussi aujourd'hui le
gouvernement ce sont les variantes du
coronavirus met d'ailleurs est ce que ce
sont les variantes en général ou bien la
variante britanniques en particulier le
nommer garman alors on va dire le virus
mute de façon naturelle et spontanée où
on connaît à peu près dix mille
mutations qui ont affecté le virus alors
pour le moment il y en a deux qui sont
un peu plus inquiétant parce qu'elle
regroupe donc deux variantes qui
regroupe plusieurs mutations et celles
ci ont la caractéristique de pouvoir se
répondent plus facilement en infectant
plus facilement non seulement les
adultes mais aussi les enfants sans pour
autant d'ailleurs c'est un point
important
augmenter le risque à l'échelle
individuelle de faire une forme plus
grave alors c'est vrai que lorsque ou
n'augmentent le nombre de personnes
contaminées
on va augmenter le nombre de personnes
plus gravement malade et donc
malheureusement le nombre de décès et
cette forme
cette variante du royaume uni d'afrique
du sud qui se répand plus rapidement
dans la population supplante désormais
les autres souches dans le sud de
l'angleterre et donc il ya effectivement
un risque qu'elle supplante les autres
souches dans les autres pays notamment
en france et qu'à ce moment là elle
s'accompagne d'une accélération de la
diffusion du virus comme ceux observés
au royaume uni et de fait effectivement
si c'est le cas bien sûr malheureusement
le
le couvre-feu de deux heures de plus
pourraient se révéler tout à fait
insuffisant et qu'il faille alors mettre
en place un confinement
malgré tout noté qu' il y a un délai
entre l'apparition du virus et sa
diffusion majoritaires dans la
population royaume-uni d'à peu près deux
mois
donc effectivement on pourrait peut-être
se dire que le fait simplement de
modifier l'horaire du couvre feu
pourrait permettre d'attendre et à ce
moment là effectivement de ne mettre le
confinement que lorsque celui ci sera
indispensable
et bien sûr je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec mon collègue évidemment il faut que
ces mecs qui s'accompagne bien sûr de
d'une intensification du respect des
mesures barrières de dépistage mieux
organisés d'une d'une communication plus
claire au niveau de la population est
évidemment d'une intensification d'une
accélération de la vaccination des
sujets à risque car c'est la seule voie
pour sortir de cette situation de
marasme
et justement sur la vaccination si je
vous comprends bien c'était variant du
cours d'un virus sont plus contagieuses
n'est pas forcément plus dangereuse est
ce que les vaccins aussi qui arrivent au
compte-gouttes son actif pour toutes les
formes de variantes christophe prudhomme
écouter ce que nous disent les
laboratoires aujourd'hui est plutôt
ration a priori c'est mutation ne
modifie pas l'efficacité du vaccin
il faudra voir effectivement si c'est
ces hypothèses se confirment parce que
pour l'instant vous savez nous nous
découvrons chaque semaine des nouveaux
éléments par rapport à cette épidémie
mais je crois qu'il faut faut être quand
même à la fois vigilant mais ne pas trop
affoler la population
il est clair que le fait que nous
sachions que ce virus mutant circulent
qu'on essaye de le détecter
pour isoler les clusters et agir de
manière efficace est un élément qui nous
met
en situation plus favorable que la
grande bretagne ou l'afrique du sud où
ont émergé ces nouveaux virus donc il
faut être particulièrement vigilant
ce qui est important je crois
aujourd'hui et c'est voyez là le retard
pris sur la vaccination ces dernières
semaines est un handicap parce que il
est clair que le vaccin ne va pas
éliminés l'épidémie du jour au lendemain
mais va atténuer la pression en terme de
nombre de malades
donc quand nous avons intérêt à ce que
la cette campagne de vaccination prenne
réellement sa vitesse de croisière et
moi je suis inquiet parce que voyez je
me suis fait vacciner hier je suis
médecin l'assistance publique-hôpitaux
de paris j'ai plus de 50 ans je me suis
fait vacciner hier et à l'issue de la
vaccination
j'attendais à ce qu'on me donne un
deuxième rendez vous que le système
informatique soit formaté pour me donner
le rendez vous pour la deuxième
injection du vaccin
eh bien écoutez j'ai été très surpris ce
n'est pas prévu on m'a dit il faut le
rappeler il faudra reprendre rendez vous
vous voyez là le dispositif n'est pas
encore complètement au point il serait
bien que au delà des effets d'annoncé
le gouvernement a effectivement accélère
dans les faits la possibilité à tous
ceux qui le souhaitent et qui sont
effectivement les populations à risque
de se faire vacciner et j'insiste moi je
ne comprends pas pourquoi on ne priorise
pas les départements qui aujourd'hui
sont les plus touchés par l'épidémie
je crois que ça nécessite à débat j'ai
eu des contacts avec de nombreux élus
locaux qui sont assez surpris du fait
qu' on ne les sollicite pas pour
organiser localement avec les personnels
de santé dans les quartiers les séances
de l'accession des médecins traitants
connais très bien sa population à risque
et donc un groupe de médecins traitants
dans une ville c'est très bien combien
ils ont le patient à risque à vacciner
donc la question c'est le gouvernement
les alençonnais de santé doivent assurer
la logistique et livrer les vaccins mais
il faut faire confiance aux personnels
de terrain aux collectivités pour
lisez dans les quartiers des séances de
vaccination ça permettra de restaurer la
confiance de la population parce que
vous savez plus de gens seront vaccinés
ceux qui acceptent aujourd'hui est bien
plus on gagnera sur la population qui
reste assez sceptique sur cette
vaccination réticente parce que j'en
pense parler
écoutez j'ai été vacciné tout s'est bien
passé il faut y aller moi si voilà donc
il faut qu'on enclenche un processus
positif sur la vaccination très
rapidement tout semaine perdue sera des
morts supplémentaires et sera lenteur de
la campagne de vaccination en france
olivier veyrat a annoncé dans la journée
que plus de 80000 soignants et personnes
vulnérables en ehpad ont été vaccinés
depuis lundi dont trente six mille
personnes sur la seule journée de ce
vendredi
est-ce que c'est rassurant quant à la
possibilité de la france de rattraper
son retard et d'ailleurs retard par
rapport à quoi vous nommez garde m
alors je suis tout à fait d'accord et ce
que ce qu'a dit mon collègue
effectivement on a l'impression encore
connaît dans une campagne de vaccination
artisanale malheureusement il n'y a pas
eu d'anticipation suffisante moi même
aussi je me suis fait vacciner hier à
l'assistance publique
alors j'ai eu la chance d'avoir mon
rendez vous pour ma deuxième injection
mais effectivement il a fallu que je
passe un appel pour la voir c'est vrai
que c'est au compte-gouttes
on est très loin d'une vaccination de
masse de la population
effectivement actuellement le chiffre
gonflé parce qu'on vaccine
essentiellement des soignants de moins
de 65 ans et à ce que je sache
moi même et mon collègue ne sommes pas
les personnes très à risque de décéder
en cas d'épidémie parce que nous savons
nous protéger il faut en fait très
rapidement étendre la vaccination aux
vraies personnes qui vont mourir c'est à
dire les personnes de plus de 65 ans et
celles qui ont des comorbidités alors je
crois que c'est un démarrage
effectivement qui commencent à augmenter
il est encore insuffisant il faut que ça
s'accélère de façon très importante
qu'on n'ouvre ses fameux centre de
vaccination au niveau local avec les
maires et les élus locaux et que l'on
lance des appels à la population par
l'intermédiaire des médecins traitants
pour que toutes les personnes à risques
viennent se faire vacciner
qu'ils habitent dans des ehpad ou
évidemment dans la communauté
alors je crois qu'à ce rythme là il est
possible effectivement qu'on atteigne
d'ailleurs c'est le l'objectif fixé par
le gouvernement le 1 million de
personnes vaccinées
eh bien merci monsieur merci beaucoup à
tous les deux messieurs malheureusement
le temps nous manque on aura l'occasion
évidemment de poursuivre ces échanges et
puis on suivra avec attention
l'évolution de cette campagne de
vaccination en france merci à tous les
deux bruno mais garbal chef du service
réanimation à l'hôpital lariboisière à
paris christophe prudhomme porte parole
de l'association médecins urgentistes de
france merci à tous les deux une bonne
soirée